-Our next guest is the
best-selling author of books
such as "A Gentleman in Moscow"
and "Rules of Civility."
His latest novel,
"The Lincoln Highway,"
is on sale now.
Please welcome to the show,
Amor Towles, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Amor, I'm so happy you're here.
-It's great to be here.
-I was very excited
about this book.
"Gentleman in Moscow"
was one of my favorite books
of the last decade.
[ Cheers ]
We have some --
And I did represent.
Back when I was doing
shows in the attic --
there's "The Gentleman
in Moscow" right there.
I was trying to support authors
by doing a very small thing.
[ Laughter ]
Did it make a giant difference
in your sales?
-We miss the Captain.
-You miss the Sea Captain.
-We miss the Sea Captain.
-Thank you very much.
Now, I actually --
I do a thing every week
called "Corrections,"
where I address
the YouTube comments
about things I get wrong.
You have hyper-specific
historical details
in your books, and you,
to some degree,
also engage with people
who tell you what you got wrong.
-Yes, this is the great thing
about the modern era
is that if you go to my website,
you can reach me directly.
-Yeah.
-And so, we get corrections,
authors get corrections
right off the bat.
And probably within 72 hours
of this book being released,
the first corrections
started coming in.
-Wow.
-And in the book,
one of the characters,
while he's in high school,
tries to burn his thesaurus
on a football field
and, by mistake, the goal post
catches on fire.
And he admires it, as the fire
goes up the middle post
and up the arms
in sort of this beautiful
standing-man burning figure.
And so, within 72 hours,
an e-mail comes in, saying,
"I really enjoyed your book,
but you should know that, in
1954, when the book takes place,
that's not
what a goal post looked like
on a football field."
[ Laughter ]
It was an 'H,' not a 'Y.'
But I was not an athlete
in high school.
And so, to fulfill
my athletic responsibility,
I was actually the manager of
the varsity girls soccer team.
-Okay.
-You know, which in retrospect,
was the right job.
-Yeah.
-That's a good interest.
But, so, I was not an athlete,
but so, there's some pleasure
to know that football fans
are reading my novel.
-That's right.
Certainly football fans
from 1954.
-And they're persnickety,
but they're good, you know.
-Now, will you -- obviously,
you can't change a book
once it's written.
-That's right.
-And it's gonna forever
be a "Y."
-No, when I go from hardcover
to paperback,
I will tend to make about
25 or 30 changes.
-Really? All based
on historical accuracy?
-Well, or based
on sort of input from readers.
There is a smaller scene
in the book
where at sort of a circus
of sorts where a woman --
a large woman rides out
on a tricycle and a tutu,
and she's chased by two seals
dressed as police officers.
And same thing.
I got an e-mail very quickly
from someone saying,
"I liked your book,
but as someone who's been
a marine biologist
for 50 years, I have to tell you
that no seal would do that
because seals do not cavort.
Sea lions cavort."
[ Laughter ]
So, yes,
when we go to paperback,
I may consider going from seals
to sea lions in that scene.
That's fantastic, and I think
that's the kind of engagement
with fans
that has a positive outcome.
And another thing
that you do for your fans --
And I don't know
if you set out to do this,
but there are some Easter eggs
in that this book has some dates
that do line up
with "Gentleman of Moscow"
even though they take place
in two different places,
and the characters
never interact or meet.
-Yeah. So, this story
takes place over 10 days
in 1954, and it's about,
you know,
three 18-year-old boys
and an 8-year-old boy
going from Nebraska
to New York City.
And as I was finishing
the first draft of the book,
it suddenly occurred to me
that this book,
which ends in June 1954,
that my last book,
"A Gentleman in Moscow,"
also ended in June 1954.
But that's a 30-year saga
set in Moscow.
But so, as I sort of began
to dwell on that,
I tinkered with the timeline
a little bit in my first draft,
and now "A Gentleman in Moscow,"
the culminating moment
of the entire novel
occurs at midnight on June 1954
where all of the telephones
in the Metropol Hotel go off,
start ringing, and events occur.
So now this book,
the culminating moment
at the end of this book
occurs at 5:00 p.m.
on the 21st of June, 1954.
And given the time change,
it means that the two books
end at the exact same time,
you know, in history.
-That's really cool,
and that's a severe case of OCD.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, that's right.
-Severe OCD. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-I would imagine --
I was lucky enough
to meet you and your lovely wife
a couple summers ago.
And I know for a fact that you
let her read your manuscripts.
And I'm wondering --
you have kids --
are your books
too adult for them,
or have they found their ways
to them, as well?
-We have two teenagers.
-Okay.
-And so,
they're certainly old enough.
But, you know, teenagers,
they're mostly there
to keep you in your place.
You know what I mean?
They don't spend a lot of time
admiring what you're doing.
[ Laughter ]
But so my wife is one of
my first readers,
and when the manuscript
was done and I gave it to her,
she likes to read in bed,
but she will not
read my work in bed,
which is nice,
because she falls asleep
when she reads.
-Right.
That is very nice.
-Yeah, and that's very intense
for the writer of his new book
to look over,
find your wife asleep.
So, she would read in the
evening and leave it downstairs,
and it turned out that my son,
Stokley, who at the age of 18,
was coming downstairs
after we were asleep
and reading the book kind of
by himself in secret at night.
-That's great.
-Which is a great compliment
from a teenager.
-But did he let you know
that he was doing that
when he was done?
Did he reveal?
-Well, he was very
reserved about it.
He was probably
one of the people
sending me e-mails
with corrections.
[ Laughter ]
-I like that --
Like, I would imagine,
when my kids are teenagers,
based on how they are now,
they would say, like, "You know,
I just want you to know
I read your book in secret."
And I would say, "And?"
And they're like,
"And I -- I finished it."
-Yeah, "I finished it."
It's another victory.
-Another victory.
Congratulations.
I'm so excited to read it.
And it's just a delight
to have you here.
Thank you so much.
-Thanks for having me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amor Towles, everybody!
"The Lincoln Highway" is on sale
now wherever books are sold,
but please support local
and independent bookstores.